[Música]
formigas certo 21 de demanda muito tempo
do nosso dia da nossa rotina para pensar
a respeito desses pequenos seres
vizinhos concorda comigo mas a verdade é
que elas têm muito mais em comum com a
gente do que a gente imagina
certo boa parte das coisas que a gente
se orgulha de ter atingido como espécie
como organismo complexo que somos no
planeta
na verdade já tinham sido atingidos
muito antes da nossa presença aqui ea
minha proposta com esse papo de hoje
aqui com vocês é que vocês depois essa
nossa conversa nunca mais olha as
formigas ea gente da mesma maneira
certo pra isso acho interessante trazer
um pouquinho a da primeira relação que a
gente pode fazer
entre os nossos grupos né a gente tem
com as formigas um grupo de de
indivíduos dentro do minc a gente chama
de operárias e obviamente a gente sabe
que operários os dados há trabalhadores
a nossa espécie certo a nossa sociedade
é bom
e pra que isto da formiga certo sendo
especialista em formiga essa é uma
pergunta que eu aprendi a responder como
cada vez mais paciência
à medida que ela sempre foi sendo feita
pra mim desde que eu escolhi esses
bichinhos para trabalhar e porque as
famílias bom o que vocês talvez ainda
não sabe o que formigas são extremamente
importantes em vários sentidos
certo a formigas por exemplo tem uma
imensa função ecológica elas estão
presentes em todos os ambientes
terrestres do planeta
não existe um ecossistema terrestre hoje
no mundo sem a presença das formigas
tá nesse sentido elas são extremamente
importantes como controladoras da
população de organismos herbívoros que
podem se alimentar de folhas vegetais
elas promovem a manutenção dessa
vegetação nas áreas onde elas ocorrem
elas são parceiras de muitas plantas das
quais elas transportam as sementes
permitem a germinação distante
as árvores de onde essas sementes caíram
ou seja essa semente filha não vai
competir com a árvore mão quadri mãe e
assim ela pode prosperar
certo a gente tem formigas também serão
extremamente importantes como a
consumidora de cá de cadáveres e
carcaças que acabam se acumulando no
solo de florestas tropicais savanas
elas são extremamente então importantes
na decomposição nessas regiões
elas também são muito importantes
economicamente formigas estão entre os
maiores consumidores de fontes
alimentares humanas né só pensar essas
formigas que atacam por exemplo a silos
de armazenagem de grãos
as famosas formigas cortadeiras de que a
gente vai falar mais um pouco aqui então
ela tem uma função importante na
economia também na relação que ela tem
como nós seres humanos
e elas têm uma importância sanitária
muito grande por exemplo como
transportadoras potenciais de
microorganismos causadores de doença em
hospitais em casa então existe toda uma
área de estudo
voltada para as formigas a chamada
mirmecologia uma área de ciência toda
dedicada ao estudo das formigas para que
isso fique mais quadros eu trouxe essa
imagem aqui pra vocês
então as formigas na maior parte das
florestas tropicais a biomassa o número
de indivíduos que as formigas apresentam
é maior
supera a biomassa dos mamíferos certo
para que vocês têm uma idéia da
importância desses pequenos seres vivos
que movimenta um planeta
ok dando seqüência então ah ah ah essa
nossa conversa
eu gostaria de apresentar para vocês os
fatos que fazem a sociedade das formigas
serem na verdade a sociedade há
propriamente dita num ponto de vista
biológico não tanto a nossa sociedade
como seres humanos mas as formigas certo
porque existe uma área dedicada à como
os organismos interagem socialmente o
nome dessa área da biologia à sócio
biologia e as formigas ocupam junto com
abelhas cupins
o ápice da evolução social porque elas
cumprem três características básicas
então elas apresentam sobreposição de
gerações dentro de uma estrutura
familiar de um ninho de formiga
nós temos sempre uma rainha na maior
parte dos casos que a mãe de todas as
operárias naquela colónia
rainha se reproduz as operárias não isso
nos leva a nossa segundo item
as formigas apresenta cuidado
cooperativo com os jovens com a prole
significa que parte dos indivíduos
dentro de uma colônia abrir mão da
própria reprodução para poder cuidar dos
irmãos mais jovens certo e finalmente a
gente tem a divisão de trabalho entre
castas nas formigas
ok a primeira divisão que a gente vai
observar essa que já mencionei a gente
tem a as rainhas como reprodutoras ea
gente tinha os operários como as formas
que são a mão de obra nas formas stern
ex
mas talvez o ápice da evolução social
informou ligas seja atingido por um
detalhe a sociedade das formigas é 100%
feminina formigas aprenderam
evolutivamente desde sempre a eliminar
funções daquele sexo que estava
atrapalhando a rotina delas
ok então não existem machos na rotina de
uma colônia de formigas os machos surgem
num determinado período do ano e ele só
tem uma única função sexual
essa é a única função dos machos eles
são efêmeros são produzidos pelas raízes
na colônia na época da reprodução e
depois eles acabam morrendo logo após
copular com as minhas viagens que se
tornaram as rainhas das suas colônias
com relação às conquistas humanas de que
a gente se orgulha tanto e as conquistas
das formigas que paralelos a gente pode
traçar bom eu diria para vocês que
muitos certo mas o que eu vou trazer
aqui são alguns dos que mais chamam a
atenção e que tira um pouquinho do nosso
orgulho da nossa arrogância como espécie
dominante no planeta
então nós temos por exemplo formigas
especialistas em arquitetura e design de
interiores
você passando por cima de um ninho de
formiga ali no quintal quando você vai
fazer um passeio no parque na praça você
enxerga um buraco no solo um buraco no
chão certo e você pode imaginar nada
pode ser mais simples natureza do que um
buraco em uma cavidade
só que a coisa não funciona bem assim
internamente a gente tem toda uma área
de estudo dedicado à arte e ao estudar
arquitetura interna e ninhos de formigas
e quando a gente faz mal
nesses ninhos utilizando gesso alumínio
derretido utilizando cimento líquido
a gente tem estruturas magníficas como
essas por exemplo aqui o nosso
pesquisador representado numa escala
real verdadeira então esse ninho ele não
é só extremamente complexo com relação
ao número de câmaras a relação ao
cumprimento à profundidade como a gente
tem por exemplo os níveis distintos de
altura entre diversas entradas no ninho
o que permite com que o ar mas carregado
de de gás carbônico ele saia por uma por
uma dessas aberturas e o ar limpo entre
portela tem o próprio ar condicionado e
sistema de manutenção interna de
oxigênio
ok tudo muito bem dividido também chama
atenção o nível máximo em uma estrutura
interna de geninho pode chegar quando a
gente compara com escalas humanas
então a gente tem esse estudo gerou um
trabalho conhecido como a cidade das
formigas certo então o que a gente está
vendo aqui uma série de pesquisadores
que na verdade injetaram caminhões de
cimento no interior de sinimbu de
formigas cortadeiras formiga saúva certo
para ter como resultado um molde interno
da colônia em escalas humanos em estaria
falando de quilômetros de túneis câmeras
e todas as outras estruturas necessárias
para a manutenção da vida de uma colônia
que nessa espécie pode atingir até 8
milhões de operárias bom caça
uma das coisas comuns a nossa espécie
quando surgimos no planeta foi o fato de
ter que obter alimento ativamente as
únicas também são assim ea gente tem por
exemplo um grupo de formigas
essas aqui são pequenas formigas
amazônicas do gênero ao menos essas
formigas são obrigatoriamente
arborícolas elas não são encontradas no
solo por exemplo ela tem uma relação
muito intrínseca com as plantas em que
elas a ocorre e por muito tempo se
perguntou por que essas formigas
formavam pequenos ninhos pequenas a
túneis estruturas que percorriam todo o
caule dessas plantas
na verdade se descobriu que esses túneis
são armadilhas são trincheiras
então essas formigas anthony estão na
sua planta elas esperam ativamente
escondidas dentro desses túneis que um
outro olho
o mesmo passe tem que escalar o que tem
de se alimentar das plantas da árvore em
que ela vive
certo assim que ela detecta a presença
desse outro organismo
as formigas imediatamente se lança e
capturas organismo pra sua própria
alimentação
então elas têm estratégias de caça
bastante elaboradas e coletivas para
manutenção econômica avançando um
pouquinho também em outras
características que a gente pode
associar com as formigas
eu gostaria de falar da agricultura todo
mundo conhece a agricultura nos modelos
humanos nos moldes humanas certo o que
você está mesmo time que a agricultura
começou muito antes da gente nesse
planeta formigas praticam agricultura há
pelo menos 58 milhões de anos
certo essas folhas que a gente vê essas
formigas cortadeiras carregando para
dentro de mim elas não servem para
alimentação da formiga
essas linhas são oferecidas para as
irmãs no interior da colônia que
mastigam essas folhas em forma uma pasta
sobre essa pasta cresce um fungo e esse
fungo é na verdade o alimento da colônia
o fungo vai ser produzido no interior da
colônia ea formiga cuida desse fungo
como fonte de alimento para todas as
operárias que habitam ali certo então é
a agricultura
no modelo mais básico que a gente
conhece praticado há 58 milhões de anos
isso começa muito cedo na vida de uma
colônia de formigas
quando há a princesa que vai ser a
futura rainha sai do ninho da mãe para
se reproduzir fundação ninho ela leva
com ela um pouquinho de si fu que vai
ser a base para que ela comece o o o
cultivo de fumo dentro do interior da
colônia dela então não é só uma
atividade conjunta como herdada da
família mente então a gente tem essa
passagem do fungo de mim pra mim o que
significa que o fungo que a gente vê
hoje ele é passado por gerações e
gerações
tanto que ele provavelmente é um clone
do primeiro fundo cultivado por essas
formigas a mais de 50 milhões de anos
a gente também tem formigas praticando
pecuária parece que estou exagerando um
pouquinho mas a verdade é essa
formigas na maior parte dos casos elas
serão predadoras ela não se alimenta de
pequenos organismos que elas encontra
nos lugares onde as linhas estão certo
o grupo de formigas na verdade
evolutivamente aprendeu que existe uma
outra maneira de obter alimento certo
ao invés de simplesmente se alimentar
esses pequenos organismos que elas
encontram nas plantas elas viram que o
organismo tem uma característica muito
interessante que pode beneficiar o que
elas fazem esses organismos aqui são
conhecidos como mt luz são insetos
sugadores de seiva das plantas
à medida que esses insetos sugam a seiva
eles não são capazes de metabolizar todo
o açúcar contido nessas silva então eles
escrevem e se essa seja na forma de uma
gotinha açucarada certo então o cozinha
de me ter welinton é uma gota açucarada
e vocês já devem saber que se tem uma
coisa que formiga gosta é açúcar
certo a forma mais rápida de obtenção de
energia então as formigas
ao invés de se alimentar desses
cemitérios elas aprenderam a cuidar
desses cemitérios
então elas não só a não permitem que
outros organismos se alimenta e dos
cemitérios como elas criam rebanhos de
mp3 nas árvores em que elas freqüentam
elas aprenderam a proteger para ter uma
fonte contínua de alimento o que a gente
chama de pecuária no formato mais
simples possível certo e isso mostra
muito pra gente do potencial que essas
pequenas criaturas têm
e aí eu tenho que dizer aqui uma coisa
que não me orgulha muito certo
há poucas coisas na história da
humanidade foram tão vexatórias ou tão
inaceitáveis em termos morais ou de
conduta como a escravidão certo o uso de
mão de obra alheia para benefício
próprio
formigas praticam algo evolutivamente
semelhante claro nenhuma questão moral
envolvida simplesmente sobrevivência
certo a gente tem uma espécie de formiga
a algumas espécies na verdade que tem
essa característica
percebam as mandíbulas elas não são a
grandes manipuladoras de alimento elas
não constroem ninhos muito bem com essas
mandíbulas e elas dependem de uma
mão-de-obra um pouco mais especializada
para isso quando a colônia atingir um
certo tamanho essas formigas que vocês
estão vendo aqui pela coloração
avermelhada
elas se organizam e promovem um saque
uma invasão
elas buscam unir
de uma outra espécie de formiga nem
sequer relacionado à evolutivamente elas
invadem e sininho e matam todos os
adultos do interior de unir todas as
operárias incluindo a rainha uma vez que
as operárias ea rainha estão mortas
o que sobra na colônia os imaturos os
jovens larvas ovinhos roupas
é isso que essa formiga quer então ela
rouba essas larvinhas essas poucas e
carrega para dentro do ninho delas
essas formigas crescem nessas lojinhas
crescem impregnados pelo motor da
colônia escravizadora ea colômbia
escravidão fiscalizadora faz questão de
impregnados com esse odor elas crescem
achando que são que irmãs das
escravizadores delas certo quando na
verdade foram seqüestrados nenhum antigo
em que elas viviam
tanto é que essas formigas as escravas
elas fazem todo o trabalho de manutenção
da colônia eles fazem todas elas fazem
todo o trabalho de proteção do ninho e
quando a população dessas escravas
diminui na colônia a centralizadora se
organizam e fazem um novo saque em busca
de pequenas escravas certo bom dava para
continuar falando uma série de outros
exemplos a respeito das formigas e com
fantásticas podem ser mas eu acho que
com isso já convenci vocês de que muito
do que a gente se orgulha de ter
atingido como conquista humana como o
organismo mais complexo no planeta
na verdade já é feita há milhões de anos
por elas as formigas certo
com um detalhe a e aí fica a mensagem
final que as formigas passam pra gente
da próxima vez então que vocês acharem
que são extremamente importantes e ocupa
um lugar de destaque natureza basta
olhar para baixo porque os organismos
mais bem sucedidos da terra chegaram
primeiro e os organismos mais
bem-sucedidos do planeta
o ápice da evolução social no planeta
representado pelas formigas são
sociedades inteiramente liberadas
organizadas e conduzidos por fêmeas
coincidência
obrigado
[Aplausos]